hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast personalizing melanoma
management with molecular diagnostics
presented by federico Monson he is a
chief medical officer at castle
Biosciences and also clinical associate
professor at Baylor College of Medicine
I am Marjorie torres of lab reads and
I'll be our moderator for today's event
we are delighted to bring you this
educational web summoner presented by
labrys Lavery's is the leading
scientific social networking website and
producer of educational virtual events
and webinars before we begin I would
like to remind everyone that this event
is interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time you
want during the presentation just click
on the green Q&A button located in the
lower left of the presentation window
and type your question into the box that
appears on the screen
well answer as many of your questions as
we have time for at the end of the
presentation also please notice that you
will be viewing the presentation in the
slide window to enlarge the window just
click on the screen icon located on the
loan rate if you have trouble seeing or
hearing the presentation please click on
the support button at the top right of
the presentation window or you six-unit
button to let us know that you're having
a problem this presentation is
educational and thus offers continuing
education credits please click on the
button in the bottom left corner and
follow the process to obtain your
credits please join me in welcoming dr.
Federico Monson I will now turn the
presentation over to him thank you very
much and thank you for the opportunity
to speak at the this event I'm gonna
talk about personalizing management with
the melanoma management with molecular
diagnostics but first I need to give my
disclosure for all of you I do employee
of Castle Biosciences and have stock
options and I will discuss some of the
tests that castle answered us so we can
get started by looking at the role of
molecular diagnostics in melanoma care
and when we look at
welcome molecular diagnostics influence
no Amaker we can start from the very
beginning at the moment of the patient
considering whether they are at risk for
developing melanoma and we can move
through the process of determining
whether a patient is a Gris moving
through the diagnosis of the disease and
determining whether a lesion that has
been identified and patient is malignant
or whether it's going to be locally
advanced or metastatic whether the tumor
has intrinsic aggressiveness and
therefore whether if there is a higher
risk of melanoma recurrence and that's
when we evaluate for prognosis and the
question for the patient there would be
you know will I survive this disease or
will I die of this disease as we move
forward in the paradigm of treatment of
care we would look at treatment
selection and whether electrodiagnostic
can help inform the treatment options
that a physician is going to choose to
manage those patients so would could
could inform a surgical option for an
informant for the punic or chemo
therapeutic option or targeted therapy
that we're going to look at and then
plus you know can influence how we
monitor the disease after we start
treatment can molecular diagnostics help
better monitor disease monitor for
recurrence and then us allowing to act
early so we're going to review each one
of these areas in which molecular
diagnostics can can have an impact in
the management of a patient with no
Anoma so the next the first part is
going to be screening is a my advice for
developing melanoma now we all know that
no money says it's a common disease if
it is one of the most common cancers is
the most common skin cancer in in the
world and suffering malignant tumor and
costing the majority of skin cancer
deaths in the world and but there are
people who are at higher
risk of developing melanoma of course
you know the timid vowels because of
mostly sun exposure but there are people
who are predisposed to that and this is
what we call had their Terry Brisbane
Prince position to melanoma between five
to twelve percent of all melanoma occurs
in patients with a strong family history
now not everybody the houses from family
history actually has had their eternal
aroma but about a little bit less than
half of these familiar melanomas are
attributed to the inheritance of a
mutation in a previous position gene and
the genes there are displayed in on the
screen now most of the inherited
melanomas and they're associated with
this ones we'll we'll review a little
bit more of those but cdkn2a is the main
one cdk4
is another fairly common one in which
mutations can lead to the development of
or of melanoma or have a higher risk of
developing melanoma now when you have
mutations in those genes the
presentation is mostly going to be by
developing melanoma but in addition to
these melanoma dominant genes there's
other genes in which normally is part of
cancer syndromes some people don't know
but people who have mutations in brca1
or brca2 actually have a higher risk of
developing melanoma the same happens for
other syndromes such as sodium a pigment
or some Calvin syndrome and live from
any syndrome all of these syndromes
while the main presentation are
different types of tumors they can also
present with a higher risk of melanoma
so how do we use molecular diagnostics
to do to understand or to help patients
who are at risk for melanoma so the
first thing is identifying which
patients we're going to test and what
we're gonna use or what's been
postulated is the rule of threes this is
basically a rule which allows us to see
or to identify people who might actually
Harbor a Hadera Tarapur disposition
syndrome for melanoma
you can see there that whether a patient
has three or more invasive melanomas in
blood relatives or three or more
invasive melanomas in an individual or
more than three melanoma and pancreatic
tumors or astrocytomas in first-degree
relatives then that's gonna prompt us to
think that these patients might have a
header type predisposition for melanoma
pancreatic cancer is actually associated
to cdkn2a and silica silica for
mutations so that's something that's
gonna that's gonna lead us to there and
this is how patients are usually
selected for for testing the testing
that we're gonna do depends on these
patterns and depends also on the tumors
that are present in the family we can
also see other patterns for example by
people presenting with uveal melanoma
this is a neuroma that arises in the eye
and this is associated with mutations
for example in that one long as their
carcinoma mesothelioma apparently Ramar
clear cell carcinoma older tumors that
are associated a territory or
disposition syndromes from melanoma so
what's the role of molecular diagnostics
here well is that genetic testing can
help us identify which gene is mutated
in these patients and again based on the
pattern of the tumors we're going to
determine which genes we are going to
actually use to diagnose your patient so
if a patient has again as I mentioned
pancreatic tumor in their family we're
gonna use cdkn2a cdk4 we're going to
test for that again as I mentioned if
there's no melanoma or clear cell renal
cell carcinoma will they look at that
one now more and more we are actually
starting to use melanoma gene panels so
this is an example of a metal in our
panel and the genes that are testing
that and these are most of the genes
that we know are now associated with a
dirty release from melanoma so molecular
diagnostics now can help diagnose these
mutations in the gloutch majority of
tumors that are asourian genes that are
associated
with melanoma because when the
development in next-generation sequence
allows to interrogate multiple genes at
a time so we don't have to do a
sequential testing strategy as we used
to do before now we can test all genes
that are associated with melanoma in a
single swoop so that's that that's how
molecular diagnostic can happen defining
whether a patient is at risk for
melanoma so what happens when we have a
patient who is going to be has a
pigmented lesion of the skin and they're
determining whether that lesion is a low
or not
so melanoma diagnosis for the most part
relies on the evaluation of a lesion by
a pathologist under the microscope the
dermatologist usually will see the
relation lesion and it will be examined
by the pathologies under the microscope
for the most part you know that tumor
based on the morphological features is
going to be classified as malignant so
it is a melanoma or benign which is a
benign nevis that that that that will
will be done without the aid of
molecular diagnostics and words does not
molecular diagnostics comes well it
comes usually in relations in which
there is uncertainty about the diagnosis
so we know that already there is a
certain number of samples or tumors in
which the features the morphological
features that allows us to diagnose a
melanoma by examination under the
microscope sometimes that's not as clear
and that leads us to can certainly in
the diagnosis also apart from that we
also know that there is some discrepancy
as with every time that we have human
intervention and in this case is pattern
recognition through the pathologist
there is certain level of discordance
and there are several papers as
some of the ones described here that you
know show that the discordance is not
that on frequent and this is usually in
cases that are difficult this is not
usually in the in the very clear cases
that you can actually diagnose everybody
will diagnose this usually happens
sometimes when when you have lesions
that again don't fulfill the criteria
that we have for our diagnosis and then
these lesions need to be evaluated in
another way because the diagnosis is
ambiguous and and this is where
molecular diagnosis can can help us
identify before we go into that I want
to look a little bit at the taxonomy of
know I'm sitting in your place and
understand a little bit of the how do I
know Mattoon regenerate because this is
what we're going to use to help diagnose
or anumana by the use of molecular
diagnostics so we know melanoma is
divided usually by two different types
those that are associated with the
epithelium and then those melanomas that
are not associated with the excellent
today we're going to actually
concentrate in the epithelium associated
melanomas and we now know that we
classify them between those that are
developing the skin that is exposed to
high ultraviolet radiation and most
importantly that when we call chronic
sun damaged skin and that leads to the
formation of melanoma and there's
another big group which is what we call
is the non chronic sun damaged skin
melanoma and these are the ones that are
we're going to concentrate more the ones
a chrome melanoma and non-melanoma and
other types of melanoma we're not going
to look at today
the most important feature here is that
UV radiation is associated mostly with
the development of chronic sun damaged
skin type melanoma and you know in a
lesser degree but also importantly is
non chronic sun damage skin melanoma now
why is this important well but because
these
ultraviolet radiation leads to damage in
nucleic acid leads to mutations in genes
and actually we now know that these
genes are different between that those
tumors are arising chronic sun damage
screen vicious tumors that arise in non
chronic sun damaged skin so when we look
at chronic sun damaged skin which is
mainly head and neck melanoma that one
is associated with mutations in n wrath
and at one cake and beer ah but not to
be 600 a mutation however non chronic
sun damaged skin which is usually the
one that occurs in intermittently some
exposed areas that would be usually
associated with be wrapped
communications specifically the vera
v600 mutation
so these helps us then actually
determine what type of melanoma we have
and where does it occur now
unfortunately it doesn't help us
actually determine whether a tumor is a
melanoma or not so while it can help us
determine what subtype of melanoma these
mutations and there will be useful in
the management of the patient as we'll
see later they don't help us identify
whether a tumor is mutated or whether a
tumor is a melanoma or not and why this
is depicted here in this graph that
shows the molecular evolution of
melanoma and when you look at this graph
you see that even in benign lesions
meaning in nearby that are benign in the
skin you can already see the appearance
of b-raf mutation so the reputation is
associated even with benign melanocytes
proliferation of benign mallamma side
neoplasia and then as it progresses to
melanoma you will see actually that even
in lesions that are not yet openly
overtly [ __ ] you're already
accumulating all those mutations that we
were talking about Andras mutation b-raf
mutations and other third mutations so
by the time we
we get to a malignant tumor that the
time we get to an invasive melanoma we
already have all those mutations the
problem then is we can't really
differentiate between a malignant tumor
versus a benign tumor by the use of
mutations now one of the things that
it's important here and that we can
actually see as it comes is if you look
at copy number alterations you can see
that those copy number alterations
actually present more commonly in the
malignant tumors compared to benign
tumors so those copy number alterations
are actually what we can use to
differentiate between malignant tumors
versus benign and that's exactly what
we've been doing for helping with the
diagnosis so when people have these
ambiguous normocytic nations they've
applied different strategies to look
into that so this is a depiction of CGH
erase or copy number erasing what you're
looking at the entire chromosome and you
can see that melanomas have a high
number of chromosome imbalances meaning
they have gains in chromosome in copies
of certain areas of chromosome and they
have losses in certain copies of other
chromosomes Wow
benign malignancies or benign morano
silly preferentially rarely have these
so we can use these to measure
chromosomal abnormalities in these
ambiguous tumors and then determine
whether if there has promised ohm or
normality or copy number alterations
then we can inform that as more likely
to be a melanoma tumor versus amoeba so
how do we do these we do this like we do
in other tumors we can measure the
number of chromosome copies or
specifically specific regions of
chromosomes that we can evaluate and we
can use these by fluorescent in situ
the decision this is one area where
where you can actually use it the
American Society when the pathology
recently did a review of these the
sensitivity of this different technique
ranges from 85 to a hundred percent and
the specificity ranges from 90 to 98
percent in identifying malignant no
anesthetic corporations or malignant
melanoma versus a benign Neera so
unfortunately the sensitivity and
specificity in ambiguous lesion is
actually a little bit lower and you know
but this is improved when you combine
the fish analysis against with the
histopathology diagnosis and that one of
the great advantages of this molecular
diagnostic technique is you can actually
look at the morphology of the side at
the same time that you're looking at
chromosome copy numbers on the
chromosome copy number alterations so
again this is one way to do it another
way is to use the array CGH or snip by
Perez to do to look at chromosomal
aberrations throughout the chromosome
and complement it can detect chromosomal
changes that can be seen in specific
subtypes so you could also do that with
a fish panel but it's a lot easier to
look at all subtypes of melanoma when
you're looking at all chromosomes it's
it seems to have pretty good sensitivity
and specificity to look at that the
caveat here is that you need to make
reliability this issue and you need
sufficient tumor tissue to be able to
extract DNA and run these micro age so
that's one of the caveats and sometimes
that might actually limit the
applicability of this technique another
new technique that is being used is
using gene expression profile so this is
looking at a messenger RNA expression
profile in this case 23 genes in which
the expression patterns differ from the
benign tumors versus malignant melanoma
and when you look at those genes you can
derive a score that is used to
differentiate
between malignant and benign IVA and you
can see here how you know malignant
tumors have a higher score compared to
benign tumors which have a lower lower
score and you can use these to help
guide the diagnosis of or help assist in
the evaluation of ambiguous nor
anesthetic neoplasms and you know it has
a pretty good area under the curve of
point 96 with the stylish Today Show
good sensitivity and good specificity
for the diagnosis of melanocytic
neoplasms here and you know when it's
been directly compared with fish it's
actually seen pretty good comparison
with fish there are certain types of non
acidic neoplasms that are not as well
distinguished by this technology or
actually even other technologies and you
know they think this new technology
seems to be acting pretty equivalent to
fish being able to be used in this
regard so in terms of a summary of how
molecular diagnostics can help here now
you know we have different options and
these are good for different things so
fish is good because it's targeted it's
a relatively accessible technique for
most of us around the world it's good
with small samples and heterogeneous
tumor because you can help us identify
copy number changes in a very small
fahsai within a lesion and you know
surface unaffected compromise between
costs technical complexity and
sensitivity array CGH actually is good
because it allows us as we said to look
at the entire chromosome and complement
so it can actually detect mutation that
sometimes might be actually mesh or
mutation but chromosomal alterations i
would actually be means by fish and the
gene expression profile is actually
upcoming technology which can seems to
have similar performance base to fish in
Ambika stations so that's how molecular
diagnostic scan helps us in the
diagnosis of these difficult to classify
on acidic neoplasm so the next step in
the management of a patient with
melanoma would be how do I manage these
patients so patients once they have in
the phonetic diagnosis of melanoma are
going to be classified patients that
have a low risk for progression and
those patients are going to then be
managed very conservatively they're not
going to be seen every year they're
probably not going to be followed but
with imaging because the risk of
melanoma recurrence is low and then
patients are classified currently based
on mostly morphological features or how
far the tumor has spread to into a
high-risk category those patients are
actually managed differently because we
want to we know those patients that are
high risk of developing metastatic
disease and we actually want to identify
metastatic disease before it you know or
as early as possible so we can actually
treat it in with good without no
authorities which I will discuss later
later so how can molecular diagnostics
help us in this case well it can help us
because there is a clinical problem in
the sense that while the clinical
classification that we use today which
is the adjacency staging system is very
helpful unfortunately even for those
patients that become diagnosed at stage
one which again is the lowest risk
category based on these morphological
ossification does those patients
actually contribute to a large
proportion of the patient that end up
dying of disease so because this group
is so large it contributes to the large
or a very large proportion of patients
that actually end up and for disease
which tells us that you know we're
missing a lot of patients who are
actually at high rates of disease but
we're not detecting based on the
criteria that we're using today
which is the criteria based on
morphology all the criteria based on how
far the tumour is advanced so a lot of
these tumors even that our stage 1 or
stage 2 that today we would classify as
a low-risk tumor or actually there are
actually patients in that category who
are actually at high risk and who are at
risk of developing metastatic disease
and dying from that metastatic melanoma
so this is exemplified in these in these
two patients that have very similar
features they're both based on
morphology would be estimated to have
very good survival however one of these
patients actually develop metastasis
very quickly after their diagnosis and
you know we couldn't have known that
based on the morphological features of
the clinical presentation of a patient
but we can actually look at molecular
diagnostics for help and this is where
the gene expression profile that is
called decision TX melanoma can help us
differentiate with between these these
two patients
so these test decision BX melanoma is
another gene expression test like the
one I mentioned before these looks at
the messenger RNA levels 431 genes uses
and validated algorithm that classifies
patients into two different categories
class one tells us that this patient
exactly at low risk for melanoma returns
and class two athlete tells us that this
patient needs at highways from no animal
returns now what how does this test work
well this test actually has been
validated and there's two publications
that have shown the validation of this
test and this test actually is able to
classify or to identify up to eighty
percent of those patients who actually
are centrally node-negative certainly
the negative is one of those ways we use
clinically to classify patients and most
of the patients who end up dying for
this disease are actually classified as
class
so these are the patients that normally
we would classify low-risk so the
central in Old Navy patients would be
the patients that we would normally
classified as low risk but we can
actually identify the problem large
proportion of those patients as class
two and move them into the high-risk
category which will allow us to actually
monitor them and be able to detect the
appearance of these things metastatic
disease earlier than we would if we only
classify them by clinical means now
these tests have been validated now in a
larger cohort of patients with 330
populations and you can see that both
for recurrent special value from distant
metastases with survival there is a
strong difference between the class one
and class two patients are again class
two patients have a much higher risk of
developing their aesthetic disease the
risk for metastatic five-year survival
is 60% in class operations compared to
91% in in class one patients again
confirming that this test actually
provides prognostic information and
there's this paper that just came out in
the last month which looked at a
prospective multi-centered registry
looking at 322 patients that actually
were evaluated in a prospective fashion
and these this study actually showed
that the tests or confirmed that the
test actually is prognostic that is
independent from the current
staging criteria or the current
prognostic factors that we use and add
additional information to these and
there is now six studies totaling more
than 1,100 patients several archival
studies that I discussed previously and
then now actually three prospective
studies that have been presented either
different
or this new publication that I just
described that shows that in a
perspective or at least in three
perspective different cohorts actually
the test confirms the prognosis now how
do we use a test or how do we use this
information how does molecular
diagnostics here inform the management
of the patient's well before having
molecular diagnostics here to help
guides ironmans we know that you know
most patients with early stage cutaneous
melanoma are going to be managed with
low intensity guidelines basically these
patients again I was going to be seen by
a physician every once in a while we're
now going to do imaging and the problem
is that we already know that we lose we
miss a high proportion of those
high-risk patients and they do not
receive the benefit of early detection
of metastasis but the problem with that
is is that actually two-thirds of
melanoma birds occur in this stage one
on three patients and we're missing a
lot of people from that could benefit
from early detection of metastasis these
notices are identified when there is
high tumor burden and therefore lower
response to therapy so how this test
actually helps us improve that is that
we can actually identify those patients
who from that low-risk morphologic pool
we can actually identify those that
actually have a high-risk tumor biology
and by actually increasing surveillance
in those patients who actually have
high-risk tumor biology we can actually
detect those metastases early and we
know now that therapeutic agents are
more effective when we have lower tumor
burden and therefore we can achieve
better response for surgical and medical
therapy when we do that it can also help
identify patients at lower risk for
disease so with those stations we don't
need to follow us strongly or so closely
and that also has benefits in terms of
reduced
exposure to radiation reduce anxiety for
the patient and with utilization of
healthcare resources so this is how
molecular diagnostics can help inform
melanoma management for these patients
so let's move to the part of pregnant
selection so so once we have a patient
who's been diagnosed who we know whether
they belong to the high risk or low risk
category we're gonna follow those
patients and a few of them are gonna
develop metastatic disease now how are
we going to manage those patients how
are we gonna do that
well this is probably one of the areas
in which molecular diagnostics have had
the most significant impact in the
management Compassion's with melanoma we
already talked about the mutations that
exist in in cutaneous melanoma we talked
about the presence of b-raf mutations in
in tumors and also about the presence of
in rats and other mutations well today
the presence of b-raf mutation in tumors
will actually be essential for the
decision of making a manager a treatment
in patients with metastatic disease we
know as we mentioned before 60
persistent - sorry 50 to 60 percent of
all melanomas harbored mutations in the
current 600 of the the VF gene and you
know why that is important is because
today we know that we have therapeutic
agents targeted agents that actually
target those mutant pyrrha and can
actually achieve very high responses and
can actually help manage those patients
with metastatic disease so these have
actually changed tremendously the
survival of patients with melanoma
before the likelihood that a patient
would be alive after three years would
be very very low today these patients
can
we leave a lot longer we have 60%
survival at 3 years after the
introduction of these targeted
therapeutic agents so how do we decide
if a patient is going to be treated with
these targeted therapeutic agents what
we decide by using molecular tests that
are going to evaluate whether a patient
has mutations in v600e currently we
probably will normally use tests that
will tell us whether there's mutation
only 600 E and B 600 K again this is the
same amino acid - just over the same
code on the different mutations in the
same codon and if there is mutations in
Vela v600e or k we're going to use ADF
inhibitor that like the maratha knee or
the Britannic to treat those patients
now we can find other mutations so
currently testing is not only limited to
be RAF we can actually use the power of
next-generation sequencing to
interrogate multiple genes and when we
do that we can interrogate other genes
like in grass which are actually
responsive to all tumors that are
mutated with endres actually are
responsible to make inhibitors and also
if we find kid mutations these patients
actually can be responsive to other
targeted agents - to tyrosine kinases
like imatinib and the SAP in it so these
have actually now changed the way we
manage melanoma and we can use molecular
diagnostic to determine which genes are
mutated in the tumor and then we can use
that information to actually determine
what management we're going to do on
that patient again this is currently
happening for tumors that are most
static so after the tumor recurred and
the patient presented with metastatic
disease or you know sometimes when the
patient wasn't diagnosed early and the
patient came to administer exists that's
what we're going to use this this
information now most of the time we can
test actually the primary tumor or even
test the metastatic tumor both of those
are valid specimens to athlete test now
a very exciting development actually
happened
a couple of weeks ago in which this new
paper came out about using the b-raf and
make inhibitors the combination of the
BRAF an event from Edmund Eve who are be
rough may be rough anak inhibitors in
the adjuvant setting but we do what we
mean from adjuvant setting is that a
patient is treated before there is
metastatic disease this is usually after
the tumor has been surgically removed
the patient doesn't have any evidence of
tumor and then we actually use a
calculation to prevent the recurrence of
disease and in this paper that just came
out again a couple weeks ago it shows
that this combination of the BRAF anew
and from Italy actually is effective in
the adjuvant setting in preventing
recurrence of melanoma in patients with
with stage three disease which is a
great news now this is not the only
agent that we can use there's other
agents like immune checkpoint inhibitors
and like a bulimic was also using in a
similar application in the adjuvant
setting however these agents actually
are seem to be actually more effective
in in this population and therefore this
is this is very exciting now again this
is in order to actually patient qualify
for being treated with these therapy
they need to actually be tested by a
validated test for b-raf mutations and
that actually can help us then determine
that that patient is eligible to be
treated with
with this with the start of the agents
so this is really really exciting now
how do we perform various testing for
the most part actually I think around
the world a lot of people use PCR based
testing you can look at multiple
different mutations with with with PCR
arts it's a relatively straightforward
technique and you can actually do that
now in many places people are doing that
I mentioned before next generation
sequencing panels because we can you can
actually look at multiple different
mutations for multiple genes at the same
time why is this important well it is
important because one thing that I
didn't mention is that embrasse actually
is a mutation that can arise after
treatment in patients who have received
be BRAF inhibitor therapy and actually
when a patient who has received be
referring error therapy develops a
mutation Andras that actually causes
resistance to the BRS inhibitor therapy
and those patients actually then will
relapse after being treated so one of
the advantages of using panels and
checking for multiple genes is that you
can start checking for the appearance of
resistant mutations in patients who are
already in treatment and that can
actually help us with the monitor
analysis which is something that I'm
going to talk next but again you know
right now for these patients to benefit
from these targeted therapies we're
going to need to use molecular
diagnostics tools to help determine
which patients should be treated with
this piece and then that's what takes us
to the last section which is Mon eternal
disease they see how do we use molecular
diagnostics to determine if a patient
should remain on the drug that has been
selected to treatment on the melanoma
treatment is
you need to change the treatment and as
opposed to everything else that I have
mentioned actually in this section we
are not yet there in terms of current
clinical use of this technology this is
sort of you know what what is coming in
the future everything else that I
mentioned before all the analyses done
for screening for diagnosis for
prognosis and for printing selection all
of those are things that are currently
already in use in our management of
therapy now monitoring disease or
monitoring the response to therapy is
really the next or one of the next areas
where there's exciting developments in
melanoma as I had mentioned before you
know we know that n grass is actually a
marker of resistance and we can actually
see these in these complications in
which people have started using quick
biopsy which is basically a blood test
and when we start looking for mutations
using the power of next-generation
sequencing or the power of a digital PCR
or other technology that allows us to
detect circulating tumor DNA in the
blood and when we can detect this
circulating tumor DNA we can monitor for
the appearance of mutations that are
associated with resistance so we can see
here for example in a patient that has a
b-raf mutation we can see the
disappearance of the various mutations
as we start the management with the BRAF
and even from ethnic but then we start
seeing in the blood the appearance of
the mutation coming back and also we can
see that the mutation that the N
recession comes up and we can see that
that patient actually is not responding
to therapy and now has a resistant
mutation in in there here we can see
again a patient that in this case was
treated with immunotherapy you know
there was response to immunotherapy we
could monitor
that response even though it's not a
targeted therapy it's an immune immune
checkpoint inhibitors therapy we can
actually monitor that response by
looking at the level of b-raf in the
blood of the b-raf mutation in the blood
and then we can see how that patient you
know relapsed and ended up with a lot of
beaver augmentation in the blood that
patient laughs but then when we when we
added the targeted agents tebron even
fermented in this case again to actually
look at the you know targeted therapy
basically targeting the beaver of
mutation and also possibly the
appearance of in reputation you can see
how that patient responds immediately to
that to those drugs so this is really
the power of these new technology of
liquid biopsy which is now going to
possibly enable us to monitor response
to therapy and to make decisions about
which drugs should we actually use for
patients so again here's another example
of a patient who has emergence of of
resistant in patients with melanoma
again you know here's another example of
in this case bi pi3 see a mutation
emerging in a patient with persistence
and we can we can you know we can do
that again this is mostly currently
being done on clinical trials on an
investigational basis but certainly
there's already tools out there that are
available clinically to start looking at
patients that have that are under
treatment in melanoma and that can help
us monitor not only the the response of
the treatment but also the emergence of
resistant mutations and we can start
looking at how we're going to we're
going to manage those right it's
important to understand that you know
these
this is all new technology we still
don't know how how well we're going to
be able to use these to change therapies
and to change management but certainly
it's a tremendous from tremendously
promising technology that we think from
our molecular diagnostics laboratories
are going to be able to help address the
issues in these in this area of melanoma
management which is monitoring disease
and being able to help plan the
management of patients with metastatic
disease in a in a more rational way
because we would be understanding what
the molecular basis of that recurrences
what the molecular basis of resistance
for for therapy is going to be so this
is really again to me an exciting time
you all of these advances in melanoma
that we know have occurred basically
within the last decade and you know now
we have a basically a tool set of
molecular diagnostic tests that allows
us to look at the continuum or to assist
at the continuum of molecular melanoma
care again at the screening and
diagnosis prognosis treatment selection
and a monitoring therapy you know is
helping improve healthcare outcomes for
patients with melanoma so the the
survival or the VA expectation for
melanoma patients a few years ago was
very dim once you had metastatic disease
it was very you know it was expected
most patients we're gonna we're gonna
die but now we have tools we have tools
to not help identify those patients at
risk we have tools to help determine you
know if we have a lesion that is
indeterminate we can actually use
molecular tools to help determine
whether it is a malignant tumor or not
again we can help determine if that
tumor that that patient have is a tumor
that is actually a biologically
aggressive tumor versus a biologically
you know indolent tumor and we can make
decisions about management for that
patient based on that we can use
molecular diagnostics to determine what
type of therapy are we are we going to
use what the repeated option we're going
to use for those patients and you know
in the future we're going to be able to
again follow up those patients over time
to determine if they respond to therapy
and adjust the therapy based on those
molecular alterations that we detect in
the blood of those stations
so the I'm just closing saying that you
know precision medicine is strongly
supported by the development of
molecular diagnostics again if we don't
have molecular diagnostics we won't
really have precision medicine or
molecular medicine the success of
molecular medicine is really based on
our ability to deliver accurate
biomarker information which then helps
us inform how we're going to manage that
patient are we going to be aggressive or
are we going to choose the right therapy
are we going to be able to monitor for
the emergence of resistance in that
patient again this is this is how
molecular analysis is essential it's an
essential part of our ability to do
precision medicine in the future and I
was just close with inviting all of you
to come to the meeting of the
Association for molecular pathology this
is where a lot of the tools for
molecular diagnostics are discussed and
if you can it would be great for you all
to join us in Salt Lake City in November
and with that I will stop and take
questions
thank you dr. Monson for that
informative presentation we will now
start the live Q&A portion of the
webinar if you have a question you'd
like to ask please
do so now just click on the green Q&A
button at the lower left of the
presentation window type your questions
into the box that appears on your screen
and click on the send button well answer
as many of your questions as we have
time for let's get started
our first question is what genes are
used for the prognostic melanoma
signature oh that's a really interesting
question so so the prognostic melanoma
signature was developed from the
literature and the team that developed
that test actually come to literature to
identify genes that had been reported as
we currently overexpress or under stress
in melanoma that was metastatic versus
melanoma as I was not metastatic and
those genes actually you know were
selected by being identified in multiple
different publications so the tests are
useless 31 genes some of the genes are
actually involved in cell migration
there's a few immune genes that are
there all the genes are described in the
publication's that I mentioned there but
but but the pathways are usually cell
proliferation cell migration some immune
modulation and some different
differentiation genes what's what's been
quite interesting is that they recently
completed TCGA the Cancer Genome Atlas
Project that reported on melanoma
mutations and as well as many other
tumors with the TCGA publication on
melanoma actually identified many of the
same genes that were actually that are
actually measured in these progressive
signatures as use associated with with
melanoma development and many of these
genes actually have been also recently
reported in you know really new
publications trying to understand
mechanisms of melanoma biology of
melanoma aggressiveness and I'm not
gonna go through the list of genes but
they're all in the complications that
are that that I mentioned during the
talk thank you for that answer our next
question is can liquid biopsy be used to
predict response to therapy that's
actually a really interesting question
actually there's there's recent
publications that have looked at what we
call tumor in mutational burden and what
what that is is that we can look at the
entire genome and look at you know how
many mutations we can identify and
there's been multiple publications
linking high mutation or board meaning
tumors that have higher number of
mutations compared to other tumors and
those tumors that have higher number of
mutations are actually associated with
with better responses to immuno
therapeutic agents to checkpoint
inhibitors inhibitors therapy the
theories there is that when there is
more mutations you have what we call the
creation of mino antigens meaning genes
that are mutated produce mutated
proteins that then are expressed on the
surface of the tumors and then those
tumors actually are easy early or are
recognized by our immune system in an
easier way or more readily our immune
system can recognize them because they
have a lot of mutated antigens in the in
the tumor surface now there is so we've
known not only from work on Noah Noah
but from work on many other different
tumors that actually these tumors with
high mutational burden actually are in
for the most part more responsive to me
and therapies with liquid biopsy come
is that it has been recently reported
actually as of last week that you can
measure the number of mutations in that
there are detectable in blood and for
that you need one of these asses that is
actually you know looks at as many many
genes I'm not just a few a few genes but
you can measure the number of mutations
that are detectable by blood and when
you have a high number of mutations
detected in this liquid biopsies
analysis these patients actually were
those that were responding to
immunotherapy for melanoma so again this
is a fairly new development and very
exciting because that means that we
could use these new molecular diagnostic
tools like liquid biopsy to really look
at the number of mutations in the blood
and perhaps help select which patients
are going to be candidates for immune
therapies checkpoint inhibitors and
therefore who can actually benefit from
those drugs so very very exciting
developments I would like to once again
thank dr. Federico Montone for his
presentation I would also like to thank
lab roots for me
educational webcast possible before we
go I want to let everyone know the
today's webcast will be available for
on-demand viewing through January of
2017 you will receive an email from
laberd's letting you know when this
podcast will be available for replay
please share that announcements with
your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event that's all for now
thank you for joining us and we hope to
see you again soon goodbye